it's the first day of school for 34
thousand students at the college of
southern nevada students will pack three
campuses across town this semester csn
has both in-person and hybrid classes
hector mejia he's been live there all
morning from the charleston campus with
the details good morning hector
hey there bianca good morning tia it's
time to dust off those backpacks and
pick up that fresh new schedule we have
the cheerleading squad here getting
ready to welcome just about 34 000
students all across the three csn
campuses many of them are starting off
the school year online
for obvious reasons but joining us live
to explain a bit more about what's going
on today in the big celebration we have
james mccoy vp here with the csn
academic affairs tell us about
everything going on today good morning
34 000 students hector isn't that
something we're the community's largest
most diverse college in the in the state
and we're super excited this energy is
incredible what do we want to highlight
as we kick off this fall semester you
bet we want to make sure that students
know that we've got a learning modality
for every single learning style whether
that be online in person or a blend of
the two another really cool thing that
we're going to continue this year is for
every student who needs a laptop or
internet accessibility through a hotspot
is free of charge as part of being a
student at csn so if they want to stay
home and do all of their learning from
home they really don't have to worry
about having to buy a laptop or anything
else that's exactly right we've got it
made it very easy it's a simple online
request form and we'll get that in the
hands of our students very quickly
that's pretty cool let's talk about the
safety protocols you bet you know we're
still in the midst of this pandemic and
health and safety continue to be csn's
number one priority in addition to
wearing masks of course all around
campus we've got sanitation stations all
over the place and we're making sure
that we're spreading out as much as
possible to ensure a safe environment so
here we are with a lot of changes last
question what are you most looking
forward to as we start this new semester
i'm looking forward to seeing our
students back bringing whatever this new
normal is as we continue down this
journey uh super excited to see smiling
spaces learning again thank you for your
time and here we see these smiling faces
ready for a new semester i'll be posting
details also it's not too late to enroll
the deadline is september 5th that's
right this sunday night all right thank
you very much reporting live hector
mckia eight news now back to you guys